معكم
التغطيه الخاصه لهذه الانتخابات النصفيه
ما هي اهميتها وكيف كانت نتائجها تاريخيا
في هذا العرض
انتخابات التجديد النصفي الامريكي تجري
هذا العام في الثامن من تشرين الثاني
نوفمبر القادم تسمى نصفيا لانها تنظم في
منتصف ولايه رئيس التي تدوم اربع سنوات
وهي تشمل جميع مقاعد مجلس النواب وعددها
435 كما يجري التنافس فيها على ثلث مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ البالغ عددها 100 اضافه الى
انتخاب حكام معظم الولايات ومسؤولها
المحليين وكذلك المجالس التشريعيه
للولايات ينتخب اعضاء مجلس النواب لمده
عامين بينما تمتد بدايه اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
ست سنوات
[موسيقى]
النواب او شيوخ تقوم الفلسفه الدستوريه
لهذه الانتخابات على انها عوده الى
الناخبين للحكم على المنظومه السياسيه على
فترات متقاربه اي كل عامين في هذه الحاله
لكن ما هي اتجاهات التصويت تاريخيا عاده
ما يخسر للحزب الحاكم الانتخابات النصفيه
في احد المجلسين او كليهما استشير
احصاءاته انه من بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه اجريت انتخابات نصفيات 19 مرات
وفي 17 منها خسر حزب الرئيس مقاعد في
الكونغرس فهل يتمكن الديمقراطيون من قلب
هذه المعادله والفوز ان تكون النتيجه في
مصلحه الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]